did a white retail worker at Macy's call
a customer the n-word that is the excuse
that some wannabe rapper is using to
justify his brothers beating the sales
clerk to a bloody pulp here is the
incident I'm sorry I'm sorry what he's
apologizing for because there's no
evidence in that video of what the guy
who was filming claimed which is that
the sales clerk called the shopper the
n-word no evidence of it at all
and I actually bet that he didn't call
him the n-word and my evidence for why I
don't think that guy who is denying
calling him the n-word called him the
n-word is because we call the word the
n-word we treat the word with such
terror such oh it's like the Israelites
using the unspeakable name of God in
olden days I so I don't think he did it
even if he did it would that have
justified that beatdown I'm not so sure
about that everybody is looking at the
last few weeks through the lens of race
I think it is much better explained
through the lens of ideology we will
talk about the n-word we will talk about
the m-word we will say things that the
left does not want us to say I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
some people get in trouble for saying
that words some people get in trouble
for being accused of saying that words
some people say that word they don't get
in trouble at all wonder what the
difference is we will get to in just a
second first though which major DC
monument will be attacked first that was
our question yesterday my favorite
answer is technically not correct but it
is generally correct it's like that AOC
distinction between being factually
correct and morally right this is from
danice's rocky Balboa's statue will be
next because he beat up Apollo Creed a
black man fair fair enough
fairness not in DC but close enough a
question I want to know today should we
cancel Jimmy Kimmel we'll get to the
Jimmy Kimmel story maybe you've seen it
already should we cancel Jimmy Kimmel
some people get in trouble for saying
the N word some people get in trouble
for being accused of saying the N word
some people don't get in trouble at all
we'll see why and how you don't get in
trouble at all but first got to thank
our friends over at paint your life
paint your life is super duper cool
having nice artwork on your home first
of all is essential it is it just makes
a house a home it makes a place so much
nicer if you want to give a truly
meaningful gift you got to try paint
your life which which gives you a
professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo at an affordable
price in a really affordable price you
can choose from a team of world-class
artists work with them until every
detail is perfect a user-friendly
platform lets you order a custom made
hand-painted portrait in less than five
minutes I love these guys I used it for
my step-brother for his wedding that the
painting is just unbelievable I've
commissioned another one now I'll let
you know how it turns out I'm sure it'll
be beautiful
get to work with the artists and every
step of the way see proofs at paint your
life calm there is no risk if you don't
love the final painting your money is
refunded guaranteed and right now you
can get 20% off your painting because
you listened to this show check it out
right now free shipping get this special
offer by texting the word Michael mich
ATL to 64,000 that is text Michael to
64,000 paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most and artwork
that I strongly strong
they recommend that Macy's employee was
accused of calling that guy the n-word
and he got this awful beatdown no
evidence that it actually happened a
white and Tifa guy a Marxist or an
anarchist or an anarchist Marxist
actually walked up to a cop a black cop
and called him the N word to his face no
consequences whatsoever he says he feels
sorry for this guy's families this guy's
not looking like he's got his life in
order exactly viewing vile insults of
this guy
sure is on a thousand drugs your your I
came I guess I can't even say it
you're a bi TCH a SS n-word is that did
I do that right I don't know what I'm
allowed to say what I'm allowed to spell
it's very confusing these days because
it varies person by person this guy was
allowed to say it completely outright to
a black guy's face no problem whatsoever
because he's got the right ideologies
you see that the store clerk at Macy's
we don't know anything about his
ideology or political philosophy we just
know that he's a white guy and we know
that he's being accused of doing
something and so he's got a piece in
Michigan he's probably one of these
terrible racist people who doesn't even
live in in Manhattan you know he doesn't
even live on the coasts he's just a
no-good deplorable irredeemable person
but this guy he looks like he's living
in the heart of Chaz Chaz chop and so
because he's got the right idea oh gee
he can get away with it what about Jimmy
Kimmel oh now it gets a little bit
trickier because Jimmy Kimmel is a
Hollywood celebrity he spouts all the
politically correct leftist doctrines so
he should get away with it but maybe he
went
too far because we now have shocking
breaking new evidence that Jimmy Kimmel
said the n-word now we already know that
he's worn blackface I guess technically
he's darkened his skin he's portrayed
black celebrities and characters that is
no longer acceptable but then there's
this album that Fox News is reporting as
an exclusive breaking news audio audio
gathered by Fox News it's a it's a joke
album in which Jimmy Kimmel allegedly
plays Snoop Dogg and sings the n-word
[Music]
[Music]
okay so you get the idea this is from
Kevin and and bean this is an LA radio
group and they put out this album years
ago and the key line there is fat n-word
in a sleigh giving gifts away and here
it's very much in the style of Snoop
Dogg especially from that era this is
not some amazing find this audio has
been on YouTube for years and the thing
that I find funny about this is this was
run news headline exclusive footage
Jimmy Kimmel says the n-word and then
they include the audio in there but they
bleep out the words oh I have no idea if
he actually said it or not I I guess I
take their word for it that they said it
but that that's the the kind of care
that it's the kind of walking on
eggshells that we have around this word
except only for certain people only for
certain people so what is it going to be
should Jimmy Kimmel be canceled this is
a question that conservatives are
debating right now because I think what
we all want to say is you shouldn't be
canceled for telling a joke you
shouldn't be canceled for saying a word
no matter how offensive the word is and
we should give comedians a little bit of
more leeway sure that's how I feel it
except that's what we've been saying for
years we let the left run roughshod over
us run roughshod over our culture cancel
the every single one of our performers
every one of our speakers every one of
our political commentators every one of
our politicians we let them all do it
and then we give them a lot of grace and
they don't learn the lesson okay the
whole the whole way that this works of
giving the left grace is if they learn
their lesson and realize that we don't
want to live in a society where no one
can say anything and everyone's got to
walk on eggshells and everyone hates
each other but if they don't learn that
if they just keep doing exactly what
they're doing then why would we why
would we hesitate seems to me the pros
of cancelling Jimmy Kimmel outweigh the
cons I don't I don't even I don't care
about Jimmy Kimmel I don't watch Jimmy
Kimmel he is the toast of Hollywood they
have him hosts all of their awards shows
but I think the pros outweigh the cons
right now he's on vacation which seems
like an excuse to me they'll probably
wait for this to blow over but there's a
chance that he gets canceled showing the
left a good example only works if
there's a chance they come around and
right now there isn't
okay they play for keeps they are no
longer just talking about tearing down
robert e lee they're no longer just even
talking about tearing down Jefferson and
Washington they are now talking about
smashing churches we'll get to that in
one second first stuff I have got to
thank our friends over at ring you know
it's very important especially these
days to feel safe in your home we are
home more than usual these days and it's
hard to keep a close eye on things more
deliveries mean more boxes left
unattended more opportunities for
packages to go missing plus you're
getting maybe some unexpected visitors
maybe people who want to do you harm
maybe it's your mother-in-law maybe
there's not a difference between those
two things with a ring you can keep your
home safe no matter where you are ring
is on a mission to make neighborhoods
safer
I give ring out as a housewarming gift
to friends of mine and it just gets rave
reviews and the thing I really like
about it is you get to feel like you're
living in the future
living in the Jetsons right you can
answer your door from in your home or on
a beach or at the office but what I
really like is that it's relatively
quite inexpensive so I feel like I'm
giving a really nice gift and it seems
great and I don't have to pay too much
money get a special offer on the ring
welcome kit right now when you go to
ring comm slash knowles canada wles that
includes the ring video doorbell 3-inch
i'm pro it is all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today go to ring comm slash knowles
kenda wles ring comm slash knowles Sean
king who was trending yesterday under
the phrase talcum X on Twitter I would
never use that phrase but that's just
what he was trending as on Twitter
because there are allegations that he is
totally white because on his birth
certificate both of his parents are
white those tho then he has countered
and said actually his father's not the
guy in the birth certificate he's
biracial and whatever that's I don't
care to get into that soap opera in
particular what I want to get into is
the the real drama these foisted on the
country which is he is now calling on
all of his thugs and goons to go smash
churches so look how we've got it's no
longer tear down statues of Confederates
because they're traitors to America then
it became tear down statues of the
founding fathers because they
racist and bad and America's terrible
but still we're talking about public
property government property now we've
gone to go to private churches and smash
their windows and tear down their
statues Shaun King writes quote yes I
think the statues of the white European
they claim as Jesus should also come
down they are a form of white supremacy
always have been in the Bible when the
family of Jesus wanted to hide and blend
in guess where they went
Egypt not Denmark tear them down tear
them down not I call on churches to
remove them then they would say the
churches should remove them he said tear
them down you you tear them down yes all
murals and stained glass windows of
white Jesus and his European mother and
their white friends should also come
down there a gross form of white
supremacy created his tools of
oppression racist propaganda they should
all come down I don't know where this
idea comes from that Jesus is is
presented most often as some Nordic kind
of God some Scandinavian or something
but it just isn't true there Jesus is
not presented as Thor at a few churches
that maybe in Iceland he is but
everywhere else he is not he's presented
as a Jewish guy which is what he is then
there's this other idea on another side
that Jesus was actually black or Jesus
was actually Arabic or something also
not true and that's why he's not
presented that way Jesus is I don't know
if you read the book but here's a
spoiler alert Jesus is a Jew and when
you look at depictions of Jesus most of
the time he looks like that if you look
at say the Shroud of Turin which is a
relic that is said to show the likeness
of Christ the artistic depictions of
Christ tend to look a good deal like
that but he wants to set it on fire he
wants to tear down the statues he wants
to smash the windows Sean King because
he doesn't like white people I guess he
says anything that if it looks white
tear it down
even if we're talking about the Son of
God and his mother the mother of God
this is only going to get more extreme I
don't know what conservatives are
waiting for we think that they're all
just joking we think they're all just
kidding they're not they're telling us
what they want to do and then they're
doing it they're telling us they want to
tear down state
choose of robert e lee then they tear
down statues of robert e lee they're
telling us they want to tear down
statues of george washington than they
are actually tearing down statues of
george washington they're going to do it
to the churches they're already doing it
there's there's actually an image coming
out of the netherlands of all places
that that has graffiti tag and paint all
over an image a mosaic of the Virgin
Mary and it says BLM on it this is going
to go on is it about race or is it about
ideologies and about the N word or is it
about the M word I think it's the latter
I think it's coming in to Marxism when
when these people tell us what they
think we should believe them we talked
yesterday about how one of the founders
of black lives matter came out and said
we are trained Marxists i we talked a
few weeks ago I called this when I said
look at the language on the black lives
matter website this is boilerplate
Marxism well now we have another example
of this which is the hashtag cancel rent
movement and you're seeing a lot of
astroturf Twitter accounts popping up
and a lot of BOTS on the internet
popping up saying we need to cancel rent
what does cancel rent me it sounds
really nice to all of us right because
none of us wants to pay our rent we like
to have the apartment but we don't like
to pay our rent
what does cancel rent mean it means
cancel private property because if you
don't pay your rent then the landlord
can't pay his mortgage if he can't pay
his mortgage he loses the property and
you you hear explicit calls for this for
many prominent left-wingers including
now and especially perhaps the leaders
of black lives matter this is what they
always do they give you a slogan that
you think that you can agree with and
buy into but that slogan is a gateway to
premises that would completely destroy
your civilization so black lives matter
as I've said nobody disagrees with the
phrase black lives matter that's why
everyone posted the square the black
lives matter doesn't mean black lives
matter black lives matter means Marxism
as the founders of black lives matter
actually told us over the past few days
canceled rent sounds great right but it
doesn't just mean canceled rent it means
canceled private property cancel your
political rights cancel your economic
rights destroy your country what is the
result of this we're actually seeing
this experiment play out in real time
over in Chaz chop named by viewers of
this show Somalia the Soviet Union and
vegans whele among other things well in
in 48 hours in Chas shop two people were
shot 19 year old was fatally shot in the
protest area according to the mainstream
media also known as the anarchist
occupied zone and then another person
was shot and hospitalized in very
serious condition this is going on all
over the place forget just Chas chop
Somalia as the most extreme example just
go to New York run by Mayor Bill
DeBlasio a commie himself well what's
going on in de Blasio's New York crime
is up through the roof there was a video
that circulated yesterday of a bunch of
thugs throwing a firecracker at a
homeless guy and watching it explode on
top of him here it is running away it's
a big explosion on a homeless guy that
it doesn't let you know I know that the
mainstream media tried to accuse white
supremacists and the phantom of the Ku
Klux Klan for committing these crimes
doesn't look that way to me this is
what's happening in Bill de Blasio's
America this is what's happening in Chas
chopped America this is what the left
wants to do are we going to believe them
when they tell us this is going to
happen you can't you can't blame them
for dishonesty they're telling us what
will happen and then they are doing it
what is the goal of all of this is the
goal all of this they have a racial
reconciliation no they're using race as
a means of effecting their ideological
ends and we've got a black lives matter
activist admitting this on television
again yesterday on CNN we'll get to that
one second first though I got to thank
our friends over at light stream you
know it can feel really really good to
finally pay off your credit cards and
start saving money get a credit card
consolidation alone from light stream
you could save thousands in interest you
can get a rate as low as five point nine
five percent APR with Auto pay and
excellent credit lower than average
credit card interest rates of over 19%
APR the rate is so fixed so that it will
never go up over the life of the loan
plus there are absolutely no fees you
can even get your money in your bank
account as soon as the day you apply
that's pretty good especially these days
people love lights during your
one customer had to say heard a
commercial checked out the consolidation
loan few hours later had my approval and
funds ready to be transferred awesome
awesome I agree apply today to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to light stream comm
slash Noll scanner wles l IG HT st e STR
e am can i spell comm slash nulls that
is light stream l IG HT st AR EA m comma
slash Knolls subject to credit approval
rate includes 0.50% auto pay discount
terms and conditions apply and offers a
subject to change for that notice light
streamed a comm slash nulls for more
information the black lives matter
founder patrisse cullors she's the one
who yesterday admitted that she and her
BLM co-founder are trained Marxists she
went on the Jake Tapper show on CNN and
admitted what this whole movement that
sprung up right now is really aiming at
not just these pie-in-the-sky ideas of
canceled rent and you know overcoming
racial oppression or what what is the
actual tactical practical goal here well
the goal of course is to get Trump out
I'm hands down Trump that only needs to
not be an office in November but he
should resign now we Trump needs to be
out of office he's not fit for office
and so what we are going to push for is
a move to get Trump out while we're also
going to continue to push and pressure
Vice President Joe Biden around his
policies and relationship to policing
and criminalization that's going to be
important but our goal is to get Trump
out the goal is to get Trump out we knew
that I said this weeks ago when everyone
was pretending this was about a man
being killed in Minnesota or a man being
killed in Georgia or and I said it's not
about any of that it has nothing to do
with that this is about the elections in
the immediate moment this is about
getting Trump kicked out in November and
then more broadly this is an issue with
liberalism but did you hear that at the
end hear what she said at the end she
goes we want to get Trump out and then
we want to push Joe Biden there are some
people I've even heard conservatives say
this
they say it would be better for America
if Joe Biden gets elected I've heard
this some conservatives think that
because they think that we're at such a
fever pitch right now Trump is so
triggered the libs that the libs are now
burning down all the cities and so maybe
we just need to give them we need to
give in we need to give them the
presidency say ok we surrender
please stop burning our city is Joe
Biden he's nothing right Joe Biden is
relatively moderate given the present
state of the Democratic Party he's been
around forever we all know him it'll
just be a return to normalcy let's just
put Joe Biden in there we'll get
moderate progressive governance and then
we'll fight again next time until they
start burning our cities again and then
we'll cave again I think that what
patrisse cullors just said here
what BLM is admitting is what you've all
got a fear you don't really have to fear
Joe Biden Joe Biden can't even spell his
own name right now he doesn't know where
he is and he happens to be in his own
basement you've got to fear the people
who are going to be around Biden Biden
is nothing I've talked to Democrats
about this they will say Joe Biden is
not with it but the people he puts
around him are think about how quickly
radical ideas have been mainstreamed in
the past few weeks you remember two
years ago president from said if we tear
down statues of Lee they're gonna tear
down statues of Jefferson and Washington
and everybody laughed at him and then
within two years it happened
well actually just within a few weeks
we've gone from Lee to Jefferson to
Washington to now now Jesus and Mary
that's how quickly things accelerate
we've gone from laughing at the green
New Deal is a big joke to living the
green New Deal basically transportation
was shut down for two and a half months
we were all thrown out of work
we all got huge massive government
bailouts trillions of dollars we're
living the test run of the green New
Deal radical ideas can be mainstreamed
very quickly do you really not believe
that some of the 20-somethings who are
going to be working in the hypothetical
heaven forfend Joe Biden administration
wouldn't agree with these radical
proposals
they all would they every single one of
them would all these 20-somethings who
just may just graduated from college
they've got degrees in cultural studies
studies of culture of culture of studies
all leftist indoctrination they're going
to be pushing for the future of the
Democratic Party don't forget Tom Perez
said that AOC is the future of the
Democratic Party not Chuck Schumer not
Joe Biden not any of those guys AOC the
College Democrats almost 100 percent of
them support abolishing police
departments this according to a new
study from college fix college fix did a
poll of 1500 college students found near
unanimity among College Democrats that
they should defund the police 94 percent
of these College Democrats I'm not
talking about College and Tifa I'm not
talking about College democratic
socialists of American College Democrats
94 percent consider rioting and looting
to be legitimate forms of protest
against allegations of racial
discrimination and police brutality that
poll was conducted by college pulse it
was taken just over the past few days
margin of error was plus or minus 3
percent and sample was drawn from an
undergraduate pool that includes over
270,000 verified college students okay
from 900 different colleges and
universities in the u.s. pretty
representative sample here almost 100
percent of them support it those are the
people who are going to be staffing the
Joe Biden administration now what is
this really about defenders of black
lives matter at least the honest ones
will admit that there's this weird
Marxist undertone they talk about
abolishing the police they talk about
abolishing the family they use words
like comrade their founders admit that
they're trained Marxists they'll admit
that but they'll say look there's a
Marxist ideological element this is just
one way to confront the problem of race
I think the reality is the other way
around
I think that these Marxist agitators are
using race and exploiting race as the
tool to push their ideological agenda I
this is what Marxists have been doing in
the United States for over a century
they know that the weak point of America
is race that's the fault line that's
where things begin to crack and so they
just poke that wound they just put their
finger in that as much as they can to
cause discord to affect their
ideological ends actually a KGB defector
I think now about 30 years ago guy named
Yuri bez men oov he he talked about this
very issue he came to the United States
he defected out of the Soviet Union he
got out of there by dressing up as a
hippie and he made it to the I believe
we made it to Athens then went to the
u.s. embassy there was obviously went
through extensive screening by US
intelligence defected the US and then
spilled the beans on what the KGB was
doing because he himself was doing it he
said that most of what the KGB did was
not espionage it wasn't James Bond we
all like to think that it was because
that's so romantic
but actually most of what the KGB did
was ideological subversion was just
trying to transform the opinions of the
American people to turn against their
own country we saw this happening in the
60s and 70s and now if if mr. Yuri bez
meant off is correct we're seeing the
fruits of that right now the way he saw
it in the 1980s the ideological
subversion had been largely successful
and now constituted a ticking time bomb
15 to 20 years to demoralize a nation
why that many years because this is the
minimum number of years which requires
to educate one generation of students in
the country of your enemy exposed to the
ideology of the enemy in other words
Marxism Leninism ideology is being
pumped into the soft heads of of at
least three generations of American
students without being challenged or
counterbalanced by the basic values of
Americanism American patriotism the
result the result you can see most of
the people who graduated in 60s drop
outs or half-baked intellectuals are now
occupying the positions of power you
cannot change their mind even if you if
you expose them to
authentic information even if you prove
that white is white and black is black
you still cannot change the basic
perception and the logical behavior in
other words these people the process of
demoralization is complete and
irreversible now what he's saying it
seems like this big wild crazy secret
knowledge but what he's saying is just
obviously correct it's just common sense
we know that Americans had been
demoralized because now even our elected
officials or supporting protests of our
very own flag we're tearing down statues
of our founders the country hates itself
without question I mean you can read it
in the New York Times you can watch it
on CNN or ABC so that demoralization has
certainly happened what was the process
of that it was infiltrating American
institutions most especially the
universities and it takes 15 20 years
and then it actually happens we know
that that's happened - we know that
there is a lot of Marxist indoctrination
that goes on in the universities if
you've ever attended a college class
you've probably experienced it firsthand
so we do know that that sort of thing is
happening it makes one wonder if we won
the Cold War from a military perspective
but ideologically perhaps we lost him
there is another school of thought
though which is that this isn't just
about Marxist I mean obviously these
idiots in Chaz and chop and the BLM
people they are Marxists and they admit
that they are but this is about
liberalism itself because okay the
Marxists are trying to attack and
infiltrate well how come the Liberals
let it happen
maybe there's something within
liberalism that is weak enough that
allows for that sort of attack and when
you think about what liberalism really
says it does seem open to that sort of
vulnerability because the premise of
liberalism is that we are constantly
liberating ourselves from the oppressive
past the basic idea of liberalism is
right there liberal liberate is that the
past is bad and the past is oppressive
and only now in modernity have we been
able to liberate ourselves from that and
this process doesn't just stop it
actually continues on and on and that's
how you get progressive liberalism
that's even in some forms of allegedly
conservative liberalism still see that
we are constantly liberating ourselves
from the bad old past into the good
right perhaps utopian future I actually
think it could be a combination of these
two things because by this view we
traditionally think of liberalism and
communism and fascism as completely
different things they're all totally
opposed to one another and yet when we
talk about communism and fascism we
realize they're not necessarily opposed
to one another as two sides of the same
coin they share a lot of the same
premises right that's why we point out
that there there are so many
similarities that the Communists had
with the fascists and the fascist ad
with the communists maybe the liberalism
has a little bit of a similarity there -
they're all about overcoming the
oppressive past giving us this new
bright utopian future they're all views
of the world that prioritize human
knowledge rational knowledge state power
they're all views of the world that
ultimately I think tear away our past
tear away our culture move us toward a
more utopian kind of ideology and maybe
because of that they're all
fundamentally flawed even liberalism the
last of the three great ideologies that
was standing after the cold war right we
we took care of fascism a long time ago
then we took care of communism in the
80s liberalism was remaining well maybe
it's not remaining for very long and
maybe we need to rethink something I
know there are a lot of conservatives
who say we're conservatives because
we're liberals we well I think that
moment is kind of over and I think now
conservatives need to offer something
that is distinct it's different it's an
alternative in the words of Phyllis
Schlafly a choice not an echo because
right now this ideology creates a lot of
absurdities most especially we just saw
a video of a white liberal black lives
matter supporter starting an argument
with a Hispanic Trump supporter and then
being asked for reparations by the
Hispanic Trump reporter and he he
supports reparations but he won't give
the reparations to the Trump supporter
will give will get all of that one
second first though I got to thank all
of you we've made it to seventy eight
thousand subscribers on my youtube
channel the Michael Nolt show YouTube
channel let's get it to 100 if you if
you wouldn't mind helping me out thank
you very much there's a lot of fun stuff
there a lot of breakouts interviews
that's
stuff if you are not already a daily why
remember you should consider getting a
reader's pass three bucks a month for
your first month though just 99 cents
you get very important articles such as
Andrew Flavin's latest enraged leftists
claim Pence's statement all lives matter
as a dog whistle to Christians and their
universal love so you get some satire
there too you also get a lot of you know
in-depth analysis from Ben or from Matt
or for me or from other other people at
the web site so head on over the only
wire that comes life subscribe we'll be
right back with a lot more
this crazy ideology is creating
absurdities so one of my favorite videos
going around the internet from these
demonstrations and protests is you have
this Hispanic guy who's wearing a
t-shirt it says God guns and Trump and
he's standing there you know where he
stands some white liberal guy walks up
to him and starts arguing with him and
the Trump supporter flips the tables on
the white just walk so well he's trying
to come up with an answer to this where
is it you want to get you want you want
me to preparations where are my rage
the guys agreeing the white liberals
agree yes you do that's right I'm
fighting for reparations but I'm not
gonna give them to you and then the
Hispanic Trump's persist so what are we
even talking about he just calls him out
he calls out the hypocrisy says okay you
want you want me to have reparations
right yes I want you to have reparations
you think I'm oppressed right yes I
think you're oppressed okay well do it
put up or shut up give me a give me my
reparations well no I'm not I don't want
to do that oh okay so this is all this
is all just a game I mean I don't think
that this white liberal meant to show
this point or meant to concede this
point but what he is showing here is
that all this racial agitation is simply
a political tool it's a an exploitative
tool to affect their ideological ends
and the ideological ends very often are
the exact opposite of what you might
hear from the racial agitators so for
instance in Chad's shop in Somalia the
leftists there have instituted a program
of racial segregation there's an area on
a big field where all the black people
are on one side and then there are these
white guards who were standing there and
so a guy with a camera shows up and he
says hey can I go into the black area
and the white guards say absolutely not
only the blacks go in there
how long's the blackout going for okay
so I have to which elate basically well
thing is I'm half Italian half Colombian
so do I get a pass to get in there or
just black okay so full black you're
saying incest three year if you if you
have experienced oppression because
you're black men you can okay thank you
so this is a ridiculous exchange
obviously this guy comes up he says well
I'm I'm Italian in Colombia does that
count how about blood am i black at all
can i Colombian I might be a little like
afro Latino am I will get to the
question of afro Latino in just a second
can I go into the area and she says no
and there explode well you can if you've
experienced the oppression of a black
person I'm reading a book right now by
Booker T Washington one of the great
black Americans in history it's called
up from slavery and he describes all the
insane segregationist ideologies that
came up when when you had a system that
was trying to figure out exactly with
precision what race someone is so he
said there was a man who went up to get
a room at a hotel and they said you
absolutely cannot you're not allowed to
stay here cuz he looked like a black guy
but then it became clear that this man
was actually a Moroccan so he looked
like a black guy and I I guess he's
African right but because he was a
foreigner he wasn't an American when
they realized this they were so
embarrassed and immediately gave him a
room at the hotel and this man learned
not to speak any more English while he
was in America the same thing on a on a
train car once Booker Washington is
there with a Native American man they
look almost the same hard to distinguish
who there but they said no the Native
American can eat here but the black guy
can't eat here when you try to parse
these little differences it's ridiculous
that's in part why segregation fell
apart is because of how ridiculous the
ideology of it had become the same thing
is happening it we're seeing the same
ridiculous ideology on the other side
we're seeing the mirror image and the
the left and is not pushing for a racial
integration or a racial equality in any
way it is it is merely an oppression
real or imagined in many cases a
completely imagined oppression that is
just completely flipped and we should
oppose it every step of the way but the
absurdity is will abound I wonder if it
might collapse under the weight of its
own absurdity probably not before a lot
more harm is done but a Ossie showed
this the other day because AOC is
getting a little bit jealous she's
envious that all of the black Ravens
politics are getting the attention and
she's not allowed to participate
in those grievance politics shoes she is
now redefined Latinos as black the first
thing that's still important is for us
to talk about racism within our
community and how we fit both how we are
both impacted by racism in the United
States across the world but also how it
exists within our own communities and
you know a lot of times I'll hear people
say okay this is about black lives
matter what about Latinos and I always
say Latinas are black we are we are
after latina and we we run an entire
racial spectrum and so we have to have
conversations around colorism and we
have to have conversations about the
African and indigenous roots from which
we come and how that's reflected in
systems of power wealth inequality and
frankly our our political system Latinos
are black that's the big brain take from
AOC news to me but well that's pretty
interesting I also can't let her get
away with that pronunciation notice what
she does she's speaking perfectly fine
English she grew up in New York Dan she
grew up in a very ritzy town in
Westchester County
so she's speaking English like a normal
person just and you know one thing I
always hear about that dienes is that
some people say that they're either
white or black but what I want to point
out is that ah penis III are or black
why are you pronouncing it that way
well I am Italian right I'm a battalion
extraction when I decide where I want to
go to dinner some nights do I say okay
well you know we've either get
hamburgers or we can go get you know
some some hotdogs or maybe we can go get
italiano yeah no I think I don't know
we'll get whatever you want we can go
get red cheese we'll get a cup of super
meat we'll go eat some me italiana food
no I don't do that I say Italian food I
don't say okay I want to go maybe I'll
have some escargot tonight let's go eat
we'll say Oh we'll say velocity would be
very good now I speak English the way
that English people talk same thing with
Letty I mean the the word Latino really
what we're talking about is the word
Hispanic that was now it's politically
incorrect to say Hispanic so you have to
say Latino but but the pronunciation of
it
is is a ridiculous performance of this
kind of racial grievance politics and I
think you're gonna see pushback I think
actually AOC is probably going to have
to apologize for this because there is a
little bit of a debate right now going
on on the left between the
intersectional woke people who say that
every racial and sexual minority has to
come religious minority they all have to
combine together and put away their
differences for a second to stop the
oppressive straight white Christian male
who thinks he's a man and so they'll all
get together and kumbaya and then
there's this this kind of older more
Marxist form which you're seeing in
black lives matter which basically says
no Hispanics are not black Colombians
are not black Asians are not black the
black experiences unique experience and
we are going to be a sort of monolithic
unit we're gonna see that debate PLC is
pretty adept at navigating the waters of
left-wing culture so I don't I don't
think she's going to have to to deal
with this you know necessarily straight
forwardly you know in a direct way but
she may have to apologize you may have
to to ease her way around it which will
be difficult with her time because she's
now being encouraged to run for Senate
against Chuck Schumer I hope this
happens there's been chatter about this
in New York circles for a while Chuck
Schumer Democratic leader in the Senate
and AOC this freshman congressman but
don't forget AFC ousted a big power
player in the Democratic Party Joe
Crowley that was how she got in in the
first place and so it's not far-fetched
one thing the air of Trump has certainly
taught us is Never Say Never things like
this can happen and actually speaking of
Trump Trump himself is encouraging IOC
to run for Senate Trump endorsed her and
said actually IOC in the Senate would be
a big improvement and she would win so
he's just doing this to needle Chuck
Schumer but it's a pretty funny point a
Bernie Sanders advisor David Sirota
is saying just gonna say something out
loud that should be obvious the fastest
way to speed up the process of changing
the corrupt do-nothing status quo
protecting culture of the National
Democratic Party is for aoc to defeat
Chuck Schumer in a Democratic primary in
2022 I want to focus
that keyword here speed up speed up the
process that is what we are seeing
happening we're seeing a process of
cultural decay speed up and so you'll
have the race hustling which has been
building for decades now on the left
that is speeding up in a way that I
don't think any of us would have
expected
don't forget what was it 12 13 14 years
ago we had more or less racial harmony
in America I think racial tensions were
as low as they've ever been and then 12
years ago we elected a black president
and people were eager to elect a black
president because they wanted to show
that America was beyond it's race
problem then you know what they did four
years later after his disastrous first
term they reelected him they reelected
him just to prove that America's past
its race problem Barack Obama perhaps
the worst president in American history
and there have been some duds but Obama
might be the worst still gets reelected
largely to make this important point
that America's past its race problem and
now what eight eight years later we seem
to be in worse racial issues than before
the left is pushing that they're pushing
that just like the Soviets pushed it
when the Soviets were around just like
our adversaries around the world are
pushing it today they know that that is
a weak point and they want to advance
their own ideological agenda we're
seeing the tearing down of statues
accelerating increase day by day we went
from Lee to Jesus very quickly we had a
couple Saints and a couple founding
fathers in the in the in the middle of
that as well things are happening very
quickly and I think it's why we need to
take this leftist ideology to its
logical conclusion that's why we don't
necessarily need to defend Jimmy Kimmel
it's why we don't necessarily need to
defend liberalism's I'm a conservative
because I'm a liberal we need to offer
an alternative something that actually
conserves our American culture or
solidarity among Americans of all
different stripes our love of our
country our love of our history Trump
began his his presidency by saying
everyone bleeds the same blood of
patriots right there the racial
differences are superficial our love of
country is what will bind us together
and what did the left immediately go for
the American flag George Washington
Thomas Jefferson they said okay if
you're not going to allow us to be
divided on race we'll go right to the
heart of America and divide ourselves we
we need we as conservatives need to
offer something that tells us why we
need to conserve our country our
traditions our history our culture our
people our our solidarity as countrymen
if we can't offer that if all we can
offer is progressivism light if all we
can offer when the left says America is
rotten to the core if all we can offer
is America is not that bad if all we can
offer when when the left says tear down
statues of Jesus and George Washington
is no just tear down Robert elay if
that's all we can offer that is a weak
sauce that is doomed to failure we need
an alternative a choice not an echo
we're gonna have to use our words very
carefully we're gonna have to choose our
tactics very carefully and we're gonna
have to be in for a bumpy road because
at the rate that things are going very
likely the only way out is through all
right that's our show I'm not gonna
listen to Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Noel's show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen